sous un bonjour et merci d'être avec
nous ce matin alors voilà on disait un
nouvelle manifestation aujourd'hui dans
toute la france il ya comme un air de
déjà vu
on voit l'exécutif qui tente de
relativiser ce mouvement mais il va
quand même l'observer de de prêt est ce
qu'on peut craindre justement un
mouvement similaire à celui des gilet
jaune
j'ai pas si on peut le craindre mais
clairement emmanuel macron a de nouveau
braqué tout un peuple une population en
décidant seul de manière totalement
autocratique sans aucun contre pouvoir
sans aucun débat parlementaire de ce
pass sanitaire de cette ségrégation
finalement entre les vacciner les dons
vacciner ceux qui veulent le pas ce
qu'ils ne veulent pas alors même que
c'est un débat qui engage toute une
société la nôtre celle d'une démocratie
libérale d'une république la france dans
quelque chose d'autre et ça c'est
inacceptable pour beaucoup de français
et on les comprend et ils seront
certains dans la rue oui et certains
qu'ils n'iront pas dans la rue soit
parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas soit parce
qu'ils ont peur aussi parce qu'on a vu
la violence d'état qui s'est déchaînée
contre les gilet jaune
donc aujourd'hui je veux bien qu'il ya
toutes ces déclarations pour minimiser
pour faire en sorte que oui c'est une
minorité qui va descendre dans la rue
mais c'est aussi il faut le comprendre
une minorité qui décide et et c'est ça
je pense l'appelle le premier rappelle
aussi des gilet jaune c'était ce besoin
de débat démocratique leur hic le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne le
fait que la démocratie devait être
vivante dans tous les échelons
finalement de la société et pas
simplement parce qu'eux mêmes à qui ont
été élus en 2017 et qu'il a tous les
droits finalement pour casser la
république sociale pour continuer à
faire des lois qui encore une fois
engage notre modèle de vie et pas
simplement parce qu'il ya un virus à un
moment donné se passe sanitaires il n'y
a aucune garantie sur la durée la fin la
mise en place le risque finalement que
ça entraîne et je suis je pense comme
beaucoup de français
abasourdi finalement de voir le peu de
réponses de l'opposition politique par
rapport à ce choix des monnaies le
maquereau qui décide seul en conseil de
défense sans aucun cadre finalement
démocratique parlementaire et c'est ça
je crois un moment de la rue alors bien
sûr ceux qui sont élus et des sites
peuvent choisir de minimiser de faire
semblant de faire un nouveau grand
départ comme l'a fait mal elle
maintenant c'est à dire 2 2
les la parole de celle qui voulait la
prendre de se mettre en scène mais ça ne
fonctionnera pas il y à vraiment là une
déconnexion des élites auto proclamées
par rapport à un peuple qui finalement
est déjà fatigué de nombreuses mesures
aussi de cette violence d'état qui est
la marque de fabrique de ce quinquennat
et qui va retourner dans la rue
aujourd'hui
depuis l'arrivée d'emmanuel macron au
pouvoir il ya des mots qui reviennent
on l'a vu par exemple avec cette
mobilisation des gilets jaunes dictature
aujourd'hui on parle de dictature
sanitaires on parle de liberté
individuelle bafoués
un homme qui est qui et seul qui décide
de tout est ce que vous comprenez
justement c'est cette colère des
français est ce que justement cette
crise sanitaire va porter peut-être un
coup fatal à emmanuel m'apprend qu'il va
peut-être se représenter lors des
prochaines élections alors et même accro
et est tenu à bout de bras un parent à
la foi de certains commentateurs
politiques des médias aussi assez
complaisant des instituts de sondage qui
permettent de faire croire de donner une
image d'un président finalement soutenu
par une majorité c'est quand même loin
des images que l'on voit que ce soit sa
descente des champs-elysées vie d'un
finalement personne n'était là et sous
les huées encore une fois que ce soit
chaque déplacement qui est une mise en
scène et non pas un déplacement facile
où il va à la rencontre des français
c'est vraiment une mise en scène avec
quelques gens qui sont castés à lourdes
par exemple il y a de cela
pas une journée un homme a dit que vous
êtes un athée monsieur macron il s'est
fait dégagé par leur service d'ordre
avec une violence inouïe
alors même qu'il n'insulte pas le
président c'est vous dire finalement le
la fébrilité de cet exécutif qui dès
qu'il va au contact des que la mise en
scène finalement des rails et bien il y
a tout de suite toute cette violence
toute cette sécurité qui arrive donc il
ya une vraie des connexions fondamental
et je crois que c'est ça le danger en
fait c'est de voir à un moment une telle
des collections et de continuer d'être
dans ce récit où tout irait bien roulé
français seraient majoritairement
heureux de ces mesures liberticides ou
après tout on va continuer alors même
qu' il y a eu la fronde dans l'armée
dans la police qui syndicats de police
qui rappelez vous manifester devant
l'assemblée nationale
et les manifestations de tous les
citoyens donc le pays est en ébullition
absolument et on a finalement ceux qui
dirigent qui pensent que tout va très
bien madame la marquise
non ça va très mal et évidemment et même
accro aura du mal à se représenter alors
il pourra toujours manipulés ou dire
qu'il ya un bilan formidable avec
l'épidémie qui sera derrière lui on peut
l'espérer pour nous tous que l'épidémie
sera derrière nous mais il reste quand
même que son projet est celui de casser
la république sociale de faire la
réforme des retraites quoi qu'il en
coûte
la réforme de l'assurance chômage et
puis combien va nous coûter cette tête
qu'ovide saemann sommes là qu'on ne le
dit pas et je crois qu'aujourd'hui il y
à cette défiance absolue entre même
certains de ses électeurs qui sont
partis certains même des députés en
marche qui sont partis la violence qui
arrivent et qui est condamnable
évidemment quand vous avez des
permanences de députés qui sont en
veille mais parce que c'est une réponse
à cette violence d'état et ne pas
l'avoir c'est créer davantage de
violence s'écrit encore davantage des
dissonances dans un pays qui a besoin de
se rassembler qui a besoin maintenant
d'être rassurés et surtout qui a besoin
de calme et nous pas de divisions or ce
que fait manuel macron depuis le début
s'est divisée s'est cassé et c'est
brutalisés merci beaucoup en tout cas
alexis poulain d'avoir réagi ce matin
sur ce mouvement de mobilisation donc ce
samedi on attend beaucoup de
rassemblement contre l'extension du pass
à lithaire merci alexis couleurs
éditorialistes merci